3837 in you Newark New York City and
we're back with the Fox News Alert the
USA has shattered its daily record in
kovat cases overnight Brian more than 77
thousand new cases reported that's
10,000 more cases than the previous
record 969 deaths were reported the
largest spike in over a month
let's bring in Kelly on Conway the
counselor to the president from the
White House now Kelly and good morning
good morning thank you for having me and
what is it let's start first with your
reaction to these new coronavirus cases
overnight in the numbers well this is
exactly why Katie and Brian and Steve
that we continue to have the coronavirus
task force talking about this dual
medical and financial crisis that the
country is facing that this president
has been navigating for many months now
I am told in the coronavirus task force
I sit right behind dr. Burks and dr.
Falchi most days when I can be in there
that we are surgeon continue to surge
supplies ICU capacity ventilators
everybody's needed the ventilator has
gotten a ventilator we continue to
provide testing and the materials that
these governors need in these hot spot
surges we did see an increase in about
June 10th to 16th it may be a lagging
indicator from some of the Memorial Day
activities when a lot of Americans just
said look I've been in lockdown for many
months first official weekend of summer
I'm going to get out there but I think
the most important thing that people can
do is what Admiral jawar our testings
are and the assistant secretary for
health for the whole nation said as
recently as yesterday which is close the
indoor bars and wear a mask I get our
schools reopened as well don't let these
kids suffer because everything is
spiking up also we had great news this
week as this president has led the
effort to the most rapid and deepest
monetary investment in vaccines and
therapeutics on this issue really in our
nation's history
dr. Fauci earlier this week said this is
great news that we had an initial test
of 45 volunteers who had coronavirus and
they built up those antibodies in their
blood stream on July 27th next week
we'll go we're going to have the tests
of 30
thousand individuals and hopefully this
will be another major leap forward to
getting the type of vaccines that we all
know will help to mitigate this damage
absolutely all of our fingers across
that it comes sooner than later
but and Kellyanne without a doubt the
administration is doing a lot the
federal government is completely
mobilized and yet how do you explain why
the president's numbers on polling with
approval and disapproval are underwater
when it comes to kovat I mean you look
at the the data from public and private
polling and Joe Biden actually beats the
President on uncovered response and Joe
Biden's in the basement not doing
anything well that has benefited Joe
Biden the less Joe Biden is better for
Joe Biden I would note that in other
polling Joe Biden's negatives have
increased because we've seen a little
bit more of him I thought he was running
for president United States but apparent
he's running for governor of
Pennsylvania because with one exception
he's not left Delaware Pennsylvania in
many many months and that is not the way
somebody should be running for president
of all 50 states he should go out there
meet people engage with them but it does
benefit him no I will I'm gonna answer
your question about why the president's
numbers may be a little softer on the
handling of coronavirus my own view
which is different than some people here
is three things one the president's
numbers were much higher when he was out
there briefing everybody on a day-by-day
basis about the coronavirus just giving
people the information they were out
there every day when we had at some
point 2,500 deaths in one day at the the
highest level and I guess it was April
or so March and April and the president
the task force were there most days
giving the information I think the
president should be doing that there
I've got some colleagues behind me well
you stop well I think some people are
encouraging him to stop he's got a task
force he has doctors and economists and
of course the vice president is leading
the task force but people want
information and this country followed
instructions they stayed inside and
socially distance and became the
teachers too they're helping and killing
and I think you're absolutely out there
talking about it because I think that
that would make it look appear that the
president was fully engaged on it
because every night at five o'clock in
the five o'clock
he would come out and he would brief the
nation on the very latest to wild
ratings people were tuning in and they
it doesn't have to be two hours but it
should be it should not be zero minutes
either and together to the president at
the podium saying I want to give you the
facts and the figures as to what we've
been able to do I mean millions of
pieces of PPE and ventilators and
vaccine development alike but also I
want to say that this president speaks
regularly the governors who are calling
him about these hot spots about these
surges working very closely with them
but that's not everywhere and we have to
make very clear I think the other reason
the president's numbers are negative
because he can never get a fair shake by
the same people doing the polling look
the Quinnipiac poll has 24% Republican
The Wall Street Journal poll 26%
Republican the ABC news/washington post
poll 24% Republican folks that is
ridiculous
to think that likely voters are only
going to be 20% Republicans so if you
have a 10% difference
it's +10 Democrat in your sample and
you're asking ballot test or approval
ratings between Biden and Trump you're
going to get a very skewed result so I
would I would caution I would urge many
the all these outlets that had the
polling all wrong in 2016 to sharpen up
to look at your science and your art
because none of them got fired by the
way they also have their jobs curiously
it's not really a meritocracy it doesn't
run I mean that was corporate America
the c-suite would have been cleaned out
the shareholders would have revolted and
the consumers would look elsewhere for
products and services but that's fine
they're all still there but their
polling is still run a hot mess I would
note though that the president some he's
at 54% in some of those polls that only
have a 24% Republican sample he's at 54%
in his handling of the economy and I
think if he gets out there and talks
about the medical and financial crises
then then I think it would be much
better than he can
he's got he's got dr. Fowler there he's
got dr. Burks dr. Redfield our doctors
are out there economists out there but
also look at what's happening with the
economy that this president is is
bullish ly leading for the country we
had just have so much more job
production he yesterday the dreg event
was incredible because this president
has said for years now his tax cut in
Job Act created a great deal of wealth
for middle-class Americans about that
business tax rate from 35 percent down
to 21 percent but the president said he
thinks he's directed agenda
it's just as important and for some
business owners property owners public
school parents small businesses it's
even more important it's we said in the
campaign last time to regulations out
for every new one end it's eight to one
now and it and it's billions of dollars
in savings I think you know this though
everything pales in comparison to the
importance of the pandemic because it
affects everybody's life business owner
family sports whatever it I don't need
to tell you that I watched Ed Rollins
essay on Lou Dobbs because I don't just
watch foxes who sometimes I watched Fox
Business and he knows this bit of change
with Brad part scale moving out and one
of the things that he brought up is you
got to bring Kellyanne back will you
ever go back and try to reproduce what
you did in 2016 and try to do the same a
mystery 20 well thank you for that Kelly
you never went away
actually Here I am and I am here at the
White House where the president wants me
to be and we've had he and I have had
those conversations many times I want to
be where my best in highest uses for the
president and I still believe that a
president running for reelection those
fortunes rise and fall mostly on what is
done where he is in this building but he
knows how involved I am I've been by his
side for four straight years trying to
push try to be a very small person
pushing up the boulder up the hill of
the Trump administration agenda and I
did see earlier and I thank you for that
I saw your segments see with Corey
Lewandowski another campaign manager
another close confidant of the president
still and continuing and when you said
it was the first woman to be campaign
manager as successfully I was also the
only woman in the debate prep most of
the time and I would expect that even if
I have to take vacation time I will be
there as well because that's really key
that's going to be must-see TV but I
think that I'm the person
longest-serving person there's certainly
longest-serving female here at lasted a
lot of the guys who works in the
intersection between policy and
communications and Donald Trump as
president has had an impact on real
people's lives you're going to see that
at our convention and you're going to
hear that in these debates Joe Biden
simply can't compete is 47 years as the
Loch Ness monster and the DC small with
the four years of the Trump record he's
just his impact on people's lives and we
will have the people there to talk about
it and this
president it was a masterful peerless
fearless debater you saw him take on
Hillary Clinton they had the Access
Hollywood tape two days later we were
there in st. Louis and he cleaned her
clock he never took her Syria never took
him seriously and then in that final
debate
October 19th 2016 president Trump did
something that no Republic or a pro-life
conservative candidate I had worked with
for decades had ever done which is this
Manhattan male billionaire who for most
of his non-politician for most of his
adult life had been pro-choice turn to
Hillary Clinton said you're the
extremists on abortion you would rip
that baby out of its mother's womb with
an hour-to-hour to go in the country
flexibly he said ooh and it really made
such a difference that plus his Supreme
Court lists his selection of vice
president pence and those were just
promises now he's delivered on that
agenda I read here the Democrats are
going to reduce their convention to 300
people that is a small second wedding
where I come from folks that's not a
political convention that's Lonnie so
here we have never went away I got you
all right never went away and didn't
necessarily I get it where it matters I
have a great connection to the base and
the grass roots I have a great my own
personal a [ __ ] with a president lots of
people trying to throw logs in my way
reflects poorly on them not on me he's
and what I want to say to you is Brad
Pascal did a great job with digital he's
a digital genius I'm glad he'll stay on
and do that I also think under Brad's
stewardship this this campaign raised a
ton of money along with the RNC they
have a huge digital infrastructure two
million or so volunteers I'm told a big
campaign staff look 2016 we were
understaffed under resource but we were
also under estimating the underdog I
think this time the president is also
underestimated underdog I would just
like to see the 2020 campaign have the
same swagger and hunger and joy on the
job that we had in 2016 so I think that
will be I have Trump's and pramana on it
lastly I'll say to you is that last
thing I'll say to you is that I see a
lot of the same trends of 2016 some
things are different but I see Joe Biden
as sort of Hillary in that way too that
he's going to try to run on the
experience he's going to have all the
king's horses all the king's men and
President Trump in being underestimated
this time we'll be able to say here is
the results I have delivered and people
will hear for the
first time some of the things that we
talk about everyday people who don't pay
attention to politics who never watch a
rally will absolutely tune in to the
convention to the debates to learn to
see the contrast alright let's see if
they do restart the president's daily
coronavirus task force maybe that was
great where the president comes out can
thank you